Hi, I'm James Murphy. And today, we're talkingabout slots in Python.
Slots are primarily a tool for saving on memory usage when you have alot of really small objects.
Using them is pretty easy. We'll go over that briefly.
But the mainpoint of this video is to help you understand
what slots actually are and how they work.
Thatmeans, we're also going to learn a little bit about what by default makes up an instance of aclass
and a little bit about descriptors and a little bit about how classes and instancesare laid out in memory.
I'd like to thank me for sponsoring myself.
Did you know that I am availablefor consulting, contracting, training and interview prep services?
I also now accept bitcoin forall business purposes including donations.
By default, classes act a lot like dictionaries
except you access attributes with dot syntaxinstead of using square brackets.
And that's nocoincidence.
Every instance of a normal class has a double under or dunder dict attribute
where you can actually view this dictionary.
Notice that this dictionary only contains instanceattributes.
So, it contains the x that was assigned on the instance.
But it does not contain the classvariable v.
The variable v would actually be stored in the capital A class object
rather than inany little a instance.
The way that attribute access works is that first Python will look inthis dictionary
and then if the key is found, it will return you that value.
If Python can't findwhat it's looking for in the instance dictionary,
then it'll start looking in the parent classes and their parent classes and so on all the way up the chain
or raise an attribute error if itdoesn't find anything.
So, in this case, a.v is found in the capital A's dictionary instead ofthe little a's dictionary.
You get an error if you try to access something that's not in any of theparent classes.
But you can add new attributes at runtime
because dictionaries are dynamicallyallocated
and you can add new elements to them no problem.
Now let's define a class that usesslots.
It's very simple. You just add a dunder slots attribute onto the class.
It should just be atuple of your instance attributes.
In this case, our only instance attribute is x.
v is a class variablenot an instance variable.
The first thing to note about using a slotted class is that instances nolonger have this dunder dict attribute.
Instead of using a dictionary,
Python will just create thespace for each slot directly on each instance.
You can still look up slotted variables and changethem as usual.
Plotting does not affect mutability.
The main difference in functionality with aslotted class is that you can no longer addnew attributes at runtime.
All the attributes aredecided when the class is defined.
However, keep in mind that the class is different than an instance.
So, I can still set class variables on the class
even though I couldn't set it on the instance.
So, it seems that slotted classes are just less functional classes.
Why would you everwant to use one?
Let's take a look at the memory usage.
Here, I'm using sys.getsizeof() to getthe size of an instance of A and an instance of B.
Here, A did not use slots and B did.
So, the Ainstance uses 48 bytes and the B instance uses 40 bytes.
Okay. So, that's a little bit less memory.
Butsys.getsizeof() doesn't give us the full picture.
sys.getsizeof() doesn't count the size ofsub-objects within an object.
So, it's completely ignoring the actual size of the dictionary.
Ifinstead I use a recursive getsize() function that actually counts the size of sub-objects and theirsub-objects and so on,
then we see much bigger numbers.
The normal class used 230 bytes whereasthe slotted class only used 68.
That's a factor of three savings just for knowing the names ofyour variables ahead of time.
Is it worth it?
The difference gets even bigger the more attributesyou have.
In this case, we have seven attributes.
And we compare not slotted versus slotted andthese are the results.
With seven attributes which I'd say is an upper middle amount for an averageclass,
we have a nearly five times memory savings.
Personally, I'm rarely memory constrained inPython.
I have 32 gigs of RAM and I don't usually work with data that big.
But in the rare case thatI'm actually using lots and lots of small objects,
a five times memory savings is a pretty gooddeal.
Thankfully if I'm using something like a named tuple, this happens automatically.
I alsotested for speed differences in creating objects, getting attributes and setting attributes
on slotted versus not slotted classes.
I found slotted classes to be faster.
But just alittle bit. Nothing to redesign your code around.
So, if instances of slotted classes don't use instancedictionaries,
then how do slots actually work?
Here, I have a not slotted and slotted class.
And thenI print out the dictionaries of both the classes.
Note that it's the instances of slotted classesthat don't have dictionaries.
The class itself still has a dictionary.
Notice that, the classobject capital B already has an x attribute
even though I've never assigned to it.
Well, printingit out didn't really tell us much.
But it turns out that this object is actually a descriptor.
Descriptors which you could write yourself allow you to modify the way that attribute accesshappens.
When Python looks up an object, if it finds that that object has a get method,
it'll actuallycall that method instead of just returning the object.
When I try to access little b.x,
it doesn'tfind the x in the little b object.
So, it looks in the super class.
Since capital B.x has aget method,
it goes ahead and calls it with the instance being the little b and the ownerbeing the big B.
The real number descriptor is written in C
and it will directly reach into theunderlying memory underneath the instance object
and return the value of x.
It doesn't have tolook up x in a dictionary.
It just remembers that all instances of capital B's store their x'sat a fixed offset relative to the base instance.
We'll see more on this in a bit.
And asimilar thing happens when you try to assign to x.
It calls the set. And then, it uses C toset the value at a fixed offset within the object.
Okay. So, there's some descriptor magic going on,some stuff that's happening in C.
But what actually is a slot?
To understand what a slot actually iswe need to enter the matrix.
We need to understand how Python objects are laid out in memory.
Theactual numbers that we're looking at may depend a little bit on the architecture of your computer.
On my computer, sizes take up 8 bytes and pointers take up 8 bytes.
So, here I have a slotted classA with no slots.
Every instance of A is laid out in memory like this.
All Python objects start outwith a reference count and a pointer to their type.
They could have other things. But for this classA, there's nothing else.
The basicsize of a class tells you how much memory an instance of the classtakes.
Our class A is just a size and a pointer,
the reference count and a pointer to the type.
So, that's 16 bytes.
And when I run it, we see that indeed A's basicsize is 16.
Similar to sys.getsizeof(), basicsize doesn't include the size of any sub-objects.
It's basically just counting up thesize of the pointers and the size.
sys.getsizeof() actually counts a little bit more though.
For thepurpose of garbage collection,
Python actually puts two pointers just before the object starts.
Andgetsizeof() actually counts those two pointers.
So, sys.getsizeof() is going to count 1, 2, 3 pointers and 1 size.
That's four times eight is 32 bytes.
And that's exactly what wesee when we run it.
But these pictures are big enough.
So, let's just focus on the instanceand ignore the garbage collection stuff.
The last class defined the slot's variablebut it was empty.
Here's what happens if you actually define slots.
Again all objects start withtheir reference count and a pointer to their type.
Directly following that is just a pointer for eachslot.
So, that's all the slot is.
A slot is really just a piece of memory
that you use for storinga particular piece of data about the instance.
This slot holds x. This slot holds the referencecount and this one the type.
So, really you should think of the dunder slots variable as namingthe extra slots that this class defines.
This is also in line with how it actually works withinheritance.
So, for each instance, we have one size and four pointers.
That's five times eight is 40bytes.
If you include the garbage collection stuff, then that's 16 more bytes and you get 56.
Let'slook at the layout of just a normal class now.
As always, we have the reference count and pointerto the type.
Then instead of having a space for x, y and z directly,
we have a space for the instancedictionary.
x, y and z don't actually show up anywhere in the instance.
You have to look insidethe data for the dictionary and that's where you would find x, y and z.
After they're initialized,of course.
There's also going to be this weak reference attribute
which would be part of theobject by default if you didn't define slots.
Explaining weakref is a topic for a differentvideo.
Just know that defining slots gets rid of it.
Go ahead and make sure you can explain why thebasic size of this object is 32 bytes.
So, what about inheritance?
What happens if you inherit froma class that defines slots but that class doesn't itself define slots?
Well, being a slotted class isnot inherited.
So, even if B inherits from A which defines slots, B will get an instance dictionary.
But remember, you should think about the dunder slots variable as being extra slots.
So, B didn'tdefine any extra slots. But it still has the ones from A.
So, if I define b dot x equals 10, thatwill not show up in the instance dictionary of b.
The x variable was a designated slot from A.
So, it will get stored in its designated spot from A.
If I do want to define more slots in a subclass,
I should only include the additional ones.
So, in this case, I add a t slot and the x, y and zones will still be there from A.
For anyone wondering about metaclasses, you will get anerror if you try to define slots on a metaclass.
You can make it have empty slots though.
Finally,you can actually define dict as one of the slots.
If you do, instances will get instance dictionaries.
In this case, instances will have a dict.But they won't have that weakref attribute.
I could also define a weakref slot if I wantedweakrefs but not dictionaries.
As we saw before, empty slots will prevent the creation of both weakrefs and dictionaries.
And if you don't define slots, then instances will have both weakrefs and dictionaries.
The last case is if you have something like a dictionary along with additionalslots.
In this case, objects will have instance dictionaries.
But specifically, the attributes xand y won't be stored in the instance dictionary.
The legitimate use cases for doing something likethis are pretty slim.
But that's the way it works.
As always, thank you for watching and don't forgetto slap that like button an odd number of times.